สวัสดีค่ะครูชี้สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกๆคน
ค่ะขอต้อนรับนะคะทุกๆคนสู่ห้องเรียน
compen  tha ห้องเรียนภาษาไทยนะแบบ
ธรรมชาติด้วยค่ะนะธรรมชาตินะคะแล้วก็วัน
นี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครูชิเนี่ยมาพบกับทุกๆ
คนนะคะในวันนี้คือวันอะไรคะครูชิวันนี้
เนี่ยวันอังคารค่ะค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 17 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนตุลาคมค่ะนะปี
พุทธศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะปีพุทธศักราช
2566 ค่ะปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
คริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะค่ะวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กครูชิก็มา
พบกับทุกคนนะคะในวันอังคารที่ 17 เดือน
ตุลาคมปีพุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราชที่ 2023 ค่ะ
นะแล้วก็วันนี้เนี่ยเรามาพบกันเนี่ยนะเรา
เอ่อครูชิจะพาครูปุ๊กไปไหนคะคือครูชิ
เนี่ยอยากจะชวนครูปุ๊กเนี่ยให้นักเรียน
เนี่ยมาคุยกับเราให้นักเรียนรู้จักว่าระ
ในในตัวเราเนี่ยเราเรียกว่ามีประสาท
สัมผัสนะฮในตัวเราอือหือ
มีปสาทสัมผัส 5 อย่างค่ะอืมประสาทสัมผัส 5
อย่างเนี่ยมีอะไรบ้างคะครูชิมีนี่ค่ะอัน
แรกเลยก็คือตาค่ะ
นะเรามีตาที่ใช้สำหรับมองเนดูนะก็จะมอง
เห็นอะไรเนาะประสาทสัมผัสที่ 1 ประสาท
สัมผัสที่ 2 คืออะไรคะปราสาทสัมผัสที่ 2
ก็คือหูค่ะไว้ฟังนะเราก็มี 2 หูเนาะ 2 ตา
2 หูเอาไว้ฟัง
อ่าค่ะได้ยินเสียงอะไรแล้วก็อ้อนะอันนี้
ปราสาทสัมที่หูใช่มยได้ยินได้ฟังแล้วก็
ปสาทสัมผัสที่ 3 ล่ะคะูชิปราสาทสัมผัสที่
3 ก็คือการสัมผัส
ค่ะสัมผัสแล้วรู้ว่าอ้ออันนี้คนอันนี้อัน
นี้โทรศัพท์
นะหรือว่านิ่มๆนะอะแข็งแข็งๆ
อื้อหือสัมผัสแล้วรู้ว่าโอ้
หยาบยาบเดี๋ยวค่ะครูชิเอามือไปทำอะไรมาคะ
มันถึงหยาบคิดิดคิดว่าครูชิเนี่ยไปุดดิน
ไงนะคะแล้วที่นี่เนี่ย
แตกหยาบค่ะแต่ถ้าอย่างเงี้ยลื่น
รื่นอืนะก็เป็นปราสาทสัมผัสที่ใช้นะผิว
หนังหรือมือใช่มยหรือว่าร้อนเย็นหนาว
เนี่ยเราก็เป็นปราสาทสัมผัสจากความเนาะ
สิ่งที่มากระทบกับเราได้นใช่ค่ะนะคะ
ปราสาทสัมผัสที่ 4 ค่ะคือนะก็คือ
ลิ้น
อืมออือโอ้โหนะลิ้นเนี่ยไอศครีมค่ะ
อื้อหือบางทีเนี่ยตาเราดูแล้วเราแยกไม่
ได้ไงเพราะบางอย่างมันเหมือนกันเกลือน้ำ
ตาล
โอ้บางอันเนี่ยทำเกลือเนี่ยเล็กๆเล็ๆ
เหมือนน้ำตาลเลยอ่ะแล้วโอหดูไม่ออกค่ะ
ต้องชิมเอ้ยเค็มเกลืออหวานน้ำตาลน้ำตาล
โอเคอืออืมหรือ
ว่าดูไม่ออกเหมือนกันค่ะไอศกรีม 2 อัน
อร่อยไม่อร่อย
เนี่ยบางทีหน้าตาดีดูดีดูอร่อยแต่พอกิน
แล้วอืไม่อร่อยก็มีหรือว่าดูอาหารเนี่ย
อย่างต้มยำกุ้งต้มยำต้มยำกุ้ง 2 ถ้วย
อย่างเงี้ยดูแล้วเอเหมือนกันแต่เวลาชิม
เนี่ย
อื้อหือ
เค็มไม่อร่อยนะอื้ออร่อยใช่มยเห็นมไม่
เหมือนกันดูเนี่ยมันไม่รู้ว่าอร่อยมยเค็ม
เปรี้ยวหวานเผ็ดอะไรอย่างเงี้ยมันไม่รู้
นะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราก็เลยต้องมีลิ้น
สำหรับเช็คได้ค่ะฟังรู้มั้ยต้มยำกุ้งไหน
อร่อยฟังไม่รู้ค่ะฟังก็ไม่รู้นะสัมผัสได้
มยคะว่าอันไหนอร่อยแค่
สัมผัสก็ไม่
รู้สัมผัสเนี่ยอาจจะรู้ว่าอ๋อต้มยำกุ้ง
นี้ร้อนต้มยำกุ้งนี้ไม่ร้อนเย็นแล้วอือ
อือหือเนาะก็สัมผัสไม่ได้ถึงรสชาติเนาะก็
เลยต้องมีลิ้นในการแยกความอร่อยหรือว่า
ความเปียบเผ็ดเค็มหวาน
อ่าอ่ะแล้วสัมผัสอีกที่ 5 ล่ะคะสัมผัสที่
5 คือจมูกค่ะ
สำหรับดมกลิ่น
อ่าแสดงว่านะของครูปุ๊กเนี่ยน่าจะได้
กลิ่นนิดหน่อยค่ะเพราะว่าจมูกเนี่ยเล็ก
ๆแต่ถ้าเกิดนักเรียนเนี่ยจมูก
โด่งจะได้กลิ่นมากเอ้ยอืเหมือนกันอ้าเหรอ
ไม่ใช่จมูกโด่งจมูกเล็กเนี่ยนะเอ่อได้
กลิ่นไม่เท่ากันเหรอคะไม่ใช่นะคะไม่ว่า
จมูกเล็กจมูกแบนจมูกใหญ่จมูก
โด่งก็ได้กลิ่นค่ะอ่าเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยทุก
คนใช่มั้ยคะที่มีประสาทสัมผัสโดยปกติเนาะ
ก็จะมี 5 ค่ะ 5 อย่างค่ะนะก็คือตาใช้มอง
นะตามองเห็นหูได้ยินเรากปุ๊กเรามีคำพูด
ที่โยงกันยังไงคะตดูดูก่อนแล้วก็หูอ่าหู
ฟังเออตาดูหูฟังเห็น
มยมือสัมผัส
ปากรับรส
อจมูกได้กลิ่นกลิ่นอ่าเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
ูชิอ่ะจริงๆอ่ะเรียงผิดใช่มั้ยตาเหมาะตา
ดูหูฟังจมูกได้กลิ่นลิ้นรับรสมือ
สัมผัสเออนะอันเนี้ยคนไทยจะเรียงแบบนี้
แต่แต่อันเนี้ยเคเรียงมาแบบนี้ไงอ้าเ้า
อาจจะแบบนี้ตึงๆหรือว่าตึง
ๆอีกทีสิคะครูปุ๊กอะไรนะตามองตาดูตาดูหู
ฟังจมูกได้กลิ่นลิ้นรับรสนะมือ
สัมผัสอ
อื
นะ
แต่วันเนี้ยวันเนี้ยครูชิคะครูสนใจเนี่ย
แหละจมูกเนี่ยแหละว่าจมูกเล็กจมูกโด่ง
เนี่ยมันได้กลิ่นเท่ากันเหรอคะได้กลิ่น
เท่ากันค่ะแล้วครูปุ๊กรู้มั้ยคะว่าประสาท
สัมผัสทั้ง 5 เนี่ยค่ะปราสาทสัมผัสสัมผัส
สัมผัสทั้ง 5 เนี้ยเนี่ยอะไรที่คุณเนี่ย
จะใช้ก่อนเป็นที่ 1 เลยอันดับแรกตาสิคะ
ต้องตาแน่ๆครูปุ๊ก
แอดผิด
ค่ะครูชิคะครูปุ๊กจะเชื่อครูชิได้ยังไง
ว่าครูชิไม่ผิดเพราะว่าก่อนที่ตาจะมอง
เห็นเนี่ยมีสัมผัสหนึงเนี่ยคุณใช้ก่อนคน
อื่นเลยค่ะไปยังไงครู
ชิครูปุ๊กรู้มั้ยคะว่าเด็กๆที่
อออกมานี่ค่ะสัมผัสแรกที่เขาใช้ค่ะคือ
จมูกอ๋อูชิเคยเป็นเด็กมา
ก่อนใช่ค่ะแต่แต่ตอนนั้นจำไม่
ได้เคยมีลูกมาก่อนอแล้วเด็กเล็กๆอ่ะค่ะ
เขาจะจำกลิ่นแม่เยังแบบยังมองไม่เห็น 1
100% นะนะคะเค้าอาจจะเห็นแบบภาพยังไม่
ชัดนะคะแต่จมูกเค้าเนี่ยชัดแล้วค่ะจมูก
เค้าเนี่ยรู้เลย
แพอแม่อุ้ม
เงียบเพราะว่าเค้าได้
กลิ่นได้กลิ่นแม่
อืเออเนคุณีครูชิกินต้มยำกุ้งครูปุ๊กกิน
ต้มยำกุ้งกลิ่นเราเหมือนกันมยอ่ะอาจจะ
เหมือนหรืออาจจะไม่เหมือนนะคะไม่เหมือน
ครูปุ๊กเค้าบอกกลิ่นของแต่ละคนเนี่ยมันน
เหมือนกับ DNA นะอืแต่ละคนไม่เหมือนกัน
ของเรา DNA ไม่เหมือนกันใช่มยหมายถึงว่า
ส่วนส่วนผสมของ DNA เนี่ยเราไม่ได้เหมือน
กัน 100% นะคะอืเราอาจจะเหมือนกัน
90% หรือ
98% นะก็จะมีส่วนที่เราไม่เหมือนกันเนาะ
ใช่แต่เค้าก็จะบอกว่าเราเนี่ยเป็นพี่น้อง
กันได้เพราะว่าเราเหมือนกันตั้ง 90%
อื้อหือครูชิคะครูุ๊อยากเห็นหน้าครูชิชัด
ๆอ่ะอออันนี้อะไรคะูชิหน้าคูชิค่ะปากคูชิ
ค่ะจมูกคุณี่ค่ะชัดหรือยังคะ
โอ้โหอันนี้เมื่ออายุเท่าไหร่
คะครูปุ๊กไม่รู้อะไรนะคะจมูกเราเนี่ย
โอ้โหเราจะรู้จักกิ่นหอมใช่มั้ยออ่ะรู้
จักสิคะูก็
ชอบดูคนนี้ซะก่อนค่ะเวลาดมอ่ะมีอารมณ์ไป
ด้วยถามสิว่าเค้าหอมหรือเหม็นนะหอม
ค่ะดูจากหน้าตาแล้วเค้ารู้สึกแชอบด้วยนะ
ใช่
ค่ะเพราะว่าถ้าไม่หอมเนี่ยคงจะเอาออกไป
แล้ว
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ค่ะแล้วก็โอ๊ยแต่ครูปุ๊กเห็นมั้ยคนเรา
เนี่ยพอเวลามีคนเอาดอกไม้มาให้สิ่งแรกที่
เราจะทำค่ะก็คือดมดอกไม้ก่อนอ่าถูกมั้ย
ว่าหอมหรือเปล่าอืใช่มั้ยทั้งๆที่ตาก็ดู
แล้วก็เห็นแล้วนะว่าดอกมันสวยแต่ก็ยัง
อยากจะดมนะว่าดอกสวยๆนั้นเ่ะกลิ่นแบบไหน
หอมหรือเปล่า
อ่าหรือหรือๆๆหรืออะไรคะเวลาครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
ทำ
อาหารก่อนที่ครูปุ๊กจะชิมเนี่ยบางคนบอกดม
กลิ่นเนี่ยก็รู้แล้วว่า
อร่อยเพราะว่าบางคนน่ะทำอาหารเนาะกลิ่น
น่ะมันจะลอยไปเลยค่ะนะเพื่อนบ้านน่าจะรู้
สึกว่าอื้อหือใครทำอะไรคะน่าน่าจะอร่อยนะ
ครูปุ๊กเคยได้กลิ่นค่ะนะครูชิจำได้ครู
ปุ๊กตอนเด็กๆอ่ะแล้วเราทำอาหารน่ะแม่ก็จะ
ตะโกนออกมาเพราะว่าแม่ได้กลิ่นแม่บอกว่า
พอแล้วเดี๋ยวไม่
แบอกพอแล้วทำไมน้ำเนี่ยมันลดลงมาแล้วมัน
กำลังจะเค็มแล้วมันกำลังจะไหม้แล้วจะสีดำ
อยู่แล้วอืทำไมรู้
ออกลิ่นมันฟ้องค่ะเห็นม
นะกลิ่นมันบอกเลยว่าไม่ได้แล้วควรจะปิด
แก๊สได้แล้วอืไม่ควรจะเปิดไฟต่อไป
นะเห็นมกลิ่นเนี่ยมาก่อนค่ะพอกลิ่นเนี่ย
โอเคเราก็อยากจะลองชิมรสดูใช่มั้ย
อ่าแต่ถ้าเกิดแบบนี้ล่ะแสดงอาการแบบนี้
เนี่ยปิดจมูกทำไม
คะก็น่าจะมีกลิ่นเหม็นมาค่ะแต่อันนี้น่า
จะเหม็นยังไม่มากค่ะก็เลยแค่ปิดจมูกครู
ปุ๊กตดเหรอ
คะ
ไม่ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงคนเเ้าปิดจมูกเนี่ยครู
ชิคะไม่ใช่ค่ะถ้าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยตดเนี่ยนะ
ผู้หญิงคนนี้เคคงไม่แค่นี้ค่ะเต้องแบบ
อแค่นั้นเองเหรอค่ะไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงคน
นี้บางที
ค่ะอืนะอันนี้เนี่ยแสดงว่ากลิ่นอันเนี้ย
กลิ่นเหม็นนะไม่เหมือนดอกไม้ที่หอมใช่
มั้ยถูกต้องค่ะแล้วมีกลิ่นอะไรเหม็นๆคะ
กลิ่นเหม็นเนี่ย
โออือหือ
อุ๊ยแปลกเนอะเวลาเราปิดจมูกเราปิดแบบนี้
ผู้หญิงคนนี้เปิดแบบเอาเน้นๆเลยแบบนี้ไม่
สวยค่ะปิดแล้วไม่สวยค่ะอ๋อไม่เห็นหน้ายัง
เห็นหน้า
ค่ะจะจำเอาว่ะ
ไไม่กลัวอาจจะเป็นแฟนกันไงแล้วถ้าเกิดว่า
เห็นแฟนกลิ่นแฟนเหม็นแล้วเราแบบเแฟนจะรู้
สึกไม่ดีไง
ก็แฟนอาจจะรู้สึกดีขึ้นมยอันนี้เออทำไม
กับเราเรียกกลิ่นเต่า
อ๋อเค้าบอกว่าเวลาเต่าเนี่ยนะเต่าเนี่ย
เวลามันไปอึใช่มยขี้ออกมาเนี่ยอือืขี้ไม่
ใช่ตด
นะอึอ่ะอ่าอึออกมาหรือว่าขี้ออกมาเนี่ย
กลิ่นเนี่ยเต่าเล็กๆนะแต่ว่าโอ้โหกลิ่น
เนี่ยไกลมากค่ะูชิเหม็นมากค่ะนะแล้วเบอก
ว่าบางคนเนี่ยกลิ่นที่รักแร้ใช่มั้ย
บริเวณนี้เราเรียกรักรักแร้รักแร้เนี่ย
บางคนเี่เหงื่อออกเนี่ยเวลาเดินๆแล้วมี
เหงื่อแล้วก็เหงื่อออกใช่มั้ยใช่แล้วมัน
ปิดอยู่ใช่มยไม่มีออกซิเจนเนี่ยเวลาเปิด
ขึ้นมาเนี่ย
โอว่ากลิ่นเหมือนๆกับเต่าค่ะขี้เต่าค่ะ
เขาก็เลยเรียกว่าคนไทยก็เลยพูดเปรียบ
เทียบนะนว่าอื้อหือขี้เต่าเหม็น
น่ะเหม็นขี้เต่า
เต่าอยู่ไหนคะรกแๆครูชี้อ่ะอ๋อนี่เหรอคะ
ชี้เต่าอย่างนี้เหรอคะค่ะเหม็นเหมือนขี้
ของเต่าเนี่ยแหละค่ะขี้เต่าเขาก็เลยแบบไป
เปรียบเทียบกับขี้ขี้เต่าไงบอกกลิ่นมัน
เหมือนกันเหม็นเหมือนกัน
อีนะคะอันเนี้ยเราบอกว่ากลิ่นเหม็นใช่
มั้ยใช่ค่ะ
อเราเราเราก็บอกว่าถ้าเกิดกลิ่นเหม็นๆแบบ
เนี้ยบางทีเราบอกว่ากลิ่นเหงื่อด้วยนะ
แล้วมันเป็นกลิ่นตัวไงอ้าใช่ๆๆูชิอนะโดย
เฉพาะบางทีเนาะบางคนเนี่ย
โอ้จะซุบซิบคุณพ่อค่ะอ้าเหรอคุณพ่อไม่
อยู่แล้วพ่อไม่อยู่แล้วเดี๋ยวพ่อได้ยิน
เดี๋ยวพ่อได้ยินคือคุณพ่อครูปุ๊กกับคุณ
พ่อครูชิเนี่ยดื่มดื่มเหล้าอนะดื่ม
แอลกอฮอล์นะดื่มเหล้ามากๆค่ะนะดื่มทุกวัน
นะทุกวันเนาะจันทร์อังคารพุธพฤหัสบศุกร์
เสาร์อาทิตย์จันทร์อังคารพุธพฤหัสบศุกร์
เสาร์อาทิตย์เนี่ยคุณพ่อดื่มทุกวันค่ะนะ
ไม่หยุดใช่แล้วก็ดื่มเยอะค่ะดื่มแล้วคุณ
พ่อเนี่ยจะมีกลิ่นตัวเนี่ยนะเวลายิ่ง
ประเทศไทยร้อนเนาะ
คุณพ่อก็จะมีเหมือนแอลกอฮอล์เนี่ยมันซึม
ออกมาค่ะมันก็เลยเป็นกลิ่นตัวคุณพ่อที่
เหมือนมีแอลกอฮอล์อยู่ด้วยโอ้โหแสดผสม
กลิ่นเหงื่อคุณพ่อเนี่ยมีเข็มแล้วก็ฉีด
แอลกอฮอล์เข้าไปไม่ต้องค่ะดื่มค่ะพอดื่มป
แล้วแอลกอฮอล์อยู่ในเลือดแล้วใช่ 90%
เป็นแอลกอฮอล์ค่ะเลือดมีแค่
10%
พอเวลาอากาศร้อนๆแล้วมีเหงื่อไหลมันจะมี
กลิ่นแอลกอฮอล์ออกมาเอออันเนี้ยเป็นกลิ่น
ตัวของคุณพ่อค่ะเพราะด้วยบวกกับแอลกอฮอล์
แล้วก็กลิ่นเหงื่อเนี่ยคุณูก็จะบอกคุณพ่อ
ซเหม็นเหม็นเหม็นเหล้าไปไกลๆเลยอื
นะก็ตอนเด็กๆคุณพ่อจะมาหอมไงอยากจะมาหอม
กูก็เอ๊เหม็นอืไม่พ่อจะหอมะคครูปุ๊ก็หอม
แต่คุณพ่อ
เหม็นขอพ่อหอมหน่อยอ่านะคุณพ่อจะมาจุ๊บ
แก้มใช่มั้ยแบบคนไทยเนี่ยจะใช้จมูก
อ่ะหอมแก้มนะแต่ว่าตอนกูุกเด็กๆไงอาบน้ำ
ก็ปะแป้งเนหอมๆตัวหอมๆแต่คุณพ่อเนี่ย
เหม็นไงตัวคุณพ่อเนี่ยมีเหงื่อมีนะ
แอลกอฮอล์เนี่ยมันออกมาเพราะว่ารอ
นะก็จะมีกลิ่นตัวที่เราบอกว่ากลิ่นตัว
เหม็นใช่มอืนะนั่นแหละแล้วก็แต่ละคนก็มี
กลิ่นที่ไม่เหมือนกันเนาะูชิอืใช่ค่ะ
เหมือนที่เราบอกนะว่ามันขึ้นอยู่กับอาหาร
ด้วยฮอร์โมนของแต่ละคนด้วยเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยบางคนเนี่ยอาจจะแบบโอ้โหอาจจะมีน้ำ
หอม
แล้ว
ครูชีว่าอาบเลยดีกว่าโอันนั้นเค่ะเยอะ
เกินค่ะูชิคิดว่าเมาค่ะเมาน้ำหอมค่ะกลาย
เป็นเหม็นเเออเนาะเพราะมันหอมมากเกินไป
เนี่ยไม่ไหวค่ะครูปุ๊กก็จะเวียนหัวค่ะเออ
เราได้กลิ่นหอมมากๆจะรู้สึกเวียนหัวใช่
ค่ะเพราะว่ามันกลายเป็นกลิ่นที่มันมันฉุน
แล้วค่ะเค้าเรียกกลิ่นฉุนหอมจนฉุนแล้วอ่ะ
เนาะเหมือนบางคนเนี่ยชอบฉีดน้ำหอมโดย
เฉพาะน้ำหอมปลอมนะน้ำหอมกอปปี้อ่ะน้ำหอม
ปลอมอ่ะแล้วก็ฉีดเยอะไม่คือคนไทยเนี่ยฉีด
น้ำหอมคือเอาง่ายๆว่าคนที่ไม่รู้จักน้ำ
หอมจริงๆอ่ะก็ฉีดน้ำหอมไม่เป็นนะบางคนก็
คิดว่าอ๋อน้ำหอมก็ฉีด
บางคน
ก็
เมาใช่ค่ะบางทีเนี่ยโอ้โหครูปุ๊กจะตายค่ะ
เวลาเดินทางนั่งรถนั่งเรือแล้วแบบต้อง
อยู่ใกล้ๆคือน้ำหอมจริงมันจะกลิ่นนึงมัน
จะแบบหอมอ่อนๆนะหอมแบบเออเหมือนอโรม่าแต่
น้ำหอมกอปปี้เนี่ย
โอ้โหกลิ่นมันมากเกินเออมันฉุนจนเวียนหัว
ค่ะบางทีเนี่ยจะอาเจียนออกมาด้วยนะเพรา
ว่ามันมันกลายเป็นแบบไม่ไหวอ่ะค่ะปวดหัว
ตุบๆๆๆๆๆไมเกรนขึ้นค่ะเดี๋วนะเรามีเหม็น
แบบเหม็นกลิ่นตัวนะบางทีเนี่ยเราจะบอกว่า
เหม็นเปรี้ยวอเหม็นเปรี้ยวเป็นยังไงคะูชิ
มันมีความรู้สึกว่าคนเนี้ยมันมีเวลาเรา
ได้กลิ่นอะไรที่เปรี้ยวๆอ่ะมันจะมีกลิ่น
ของมันกลิ่นความเปรี้ยวอ่ะเลมอนเหรอคะ
ำคือถ้ามะนาวเนี่ยมันจะมีกลิ่นเปรี้ยว
ด้วยแล้วก็กลิ่นหอมด้วยนะคะมันจะมีกลิ่น 2
กลิ่นด้วยกันใช่มั้ยแต่กลิ่นที่ออก
เปรี้ยวๆเนี่ยคิดว่ามันเก็บไว้นานจน
เปรี้ยวเบอกว่าเหงื่อคนเราเนี่ยเหงื่อที่
ออกมาเนเวลาไปวิ่งๆๆออกกำลังกายมีเหงื่อ
เนี่ยเหงื่อแต่ละคนเนี่ยก็ไม่เหมือนกัน
บางคนเนี่ยไหลเข้าปากเนี่ยอื
เค็มบางคนเหงื่อไหลเนี่ยึบอื
เปรี้ยวเออกูปุ๊บพูดแบบเนี้ยใช่เลยเพราะ
บางคนใส่สร้อยทองอ่ะนักเรียนใส่สร้อยที่
เป็นทองแล้วถ้าเหงื่อเราเนี่ยเค็มอือฮึ
สร้อยทองจะเป็นเปลี่ยนเป็นสีดำเลยใช่แต่
ถ้าเหงื่อใครเนี่ยเปรี้ยวพอเวลาโดนสร้อย
ท้อง
โอโหสว่างเลยค่ะอืตกลงแล้วเป็นคนเปรี้ยว
หรือคนเค็ม
คะอืน่าจะ 2 อย่างด้วยกันค่ะขอชิม
ก่อนน่าจะ 2 อย่างด้วยกันค่ะเพราะว่าใส่
ทองกับเงินก็ไม่ค่อยดำค่ะนะอ่าแต่ว่า
เหงื่อละไหลเข้าปก็เค็มอยู่นะคะูชิก็
เหงื่อของครูชิก็เค็มค่ะเวลาครูชิกินข้าว
เนี่ยไม่ต้องน้ำปลาค่ะกินข้าวแล้ว
ก็ไม่ใช่ค่ะูชิแค่เอามือหยิบก็เค็มแล้ว
อ๋อเค็มที่มือแล้วใช่มั้ยนะคะทีนี้มันยัง
มีความเหม็นอีกค่ะครูกุ๊กมีเหม็นอะไรอีก
คะเมื่อกี้เรามีเหม็นเปรี้ยวเหม็นฉุนที่
กลิ่นแรงๆก็กลายเป็นเหม็นฉุนใช่มั้ยใช่
เพราะว่าอย่างรักแรที่ครูชิบอกที่ระบบ
เหม็นขี้เต่าอ่ะอันเนี้ยคือมันเหมือนพอ
มันเหงื่อมันออกเนี่ยแล้วมันมีความเค้าอบ
ไว้เนาะมันไม่ได้เปิดเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
อากาศไม่ได้ระบายออกค่ะมันก็จะกลิ่นแรง
ขึ้นแล้วก็เหม็นเราบอกว่าฉุนกลิ่นจะฉุน
หรือแอลกอฮอล์แบบคุณพ่อที่เราบอกอ่ะดื่ม
แอลกอฮอล์มากๆแล้วกลิ่นที่มันออกมาจากตัว
ระเหยออกมากลิ่นเหม็นมันก็จะฉุนมากนะที่
ครูปุ๊กบอกว่าฉีดน้ำหอมมากเกินไปจนฉุนใช่
มั้ยใช่อันนั้นมันไม่ใช่หอมแล้วใช่มั้ย
มันกลายเป็นจากหอมน้ำหอมนะแต่ว่ามันฉุ่น
มากจนแบบอืนะอาจจะกลายเป็นเหม็นไปแล้ว
อื้อหือทีนี้ก็ยังมีไงคะมีเหม็นอีกอย่าง
นึงเราเรียกว่าอย่างขยะเนี่ยเราเรียกว่า
เหม็น
เน่า
อ๋อเหม็นเน่าเนี่ยหมายถึงว่าอาหารอาจจะ
ทิ้งไว้หลายวันเหรอคะอือออันนี้อะไรครับ
อันนี้อันนี้ก็ปลาตายอยู่ในน้ำค่ะแล้วมัน
ส่งกลิ่นเหม็นของปลาตายเนี่ยเราบอกเหม็น
เน่าอ๋อขนตัวอะไตายอยู่เหม็นเน่ามากเลยเ
เวลาสัตว์ที่ตายหรือคนที่ตายเนี่ยมันจะ
ค่อยๆเนาะเนื้อเนี่ยมันจะเน่าแล้วก็จะส่ง
กลิ่นที่เหม็นมากๆอ่ะเราโอ้โหเหม็นเน่า
มากเลย
อือหรือเราเจออะไรที่แบบตายไปนานๆนะแล้ว
บอกโอ้โหอันนี้เหม็นไม่ธรรมดานะเหม็นเน่า
หรือบางทีเราเปิดตู้เย็นมาค่ะเหม็นเน่า
เหรอคะมันมี 2 กลิ่นด้วยกันค่ะคือมันมี
กลิ่นเหม็นอับอับก็คือเก็บไว้นานๆจน
กระทั่งแบบมันมันมันเก็บกลิ่นที่ไม่ดีเอา
ไว้นานๆมันจะรู้สึกแบบอับอับเหมือนมเสื้อ
ผ้าที่ซักแล้วไปตากเนี่ยมันไม่แห้งแล้ว
เก็บมาใส่ในตู้เสื้อผ้าเนาะปิดเอาไว้อ่ะ
แล้วมันไม่มีออกซิเจนไม่มีอากาศที่ระบาย
เข้าออกอ่ะแล้วเสื้อผ้าที่มีความชื้นมี
น้ำนิดหน่อยอ่ะนักเรียนมันก็จะมีกลิ่น
เนี่ยที่แบบอบไปทั่วเนาะคิดว่านักเรียน
น่าจะเคยเคยได้กลิ่นเวลานักเรียนเนี่ย
กลับแบบเดินทางไปไหนนะนานาหลายๆวันนะตู้
เสื้อผ้าเนี่ยปิดเอาไว้อ่ะนะไม่ได้เปิด
ทุกวันใช่มยอันเนี้ยอาจจะปิดไว้ 1 เดือน
พอเปิดออกมาเนี่ยจะได้กลิ่นค่ะไม่ว่าจะ
เป็นกลิ่นของไม้รวมกับกลิ่นของเสื้อผ้า
ที่อาจจะแบบมีความชื้นเนาเพราะว่าในอากาศ
อาจจะมีชืความชื้นมีน้ำในอากาศนะมันก็อาจ
จะทำให้มีกลิ่นอับที่มันอบอยู่ข้างในอ่ะ
ปกติเมยเราจะเปิดเราเปิดออกเลยบ่อยๆมันก็
จะมีอากาศที่เข้าออกทำให้ไม่อับแต่เมื่อ
ไหร่ที่คุณปิดไว้นานๆน่ะเนาะมันก็จะเกิด
กลิ่นที่มันเค้าเรียกว่ากลิ่นอับอ่าเหม็น
อับใช่เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราเปิดตู้เย็นออก
มามันมีทั้งกลิ่นอับแล้วก็กลิ่นเน่าอาจจะ
แบบหมู 1 เดือนแล้วอยู่ในไม่ได้อยู่
ฟิสเซอร์แต่อยู่ในหอ้าวหรือว่าอาหารก็ได้
นะอาหารที่หลายวันแล้วแล้วเราเอาใส่ถ้วย
ใส่ชามแล้วเอาข้าตู้เย็นไว้ไม่มีฝาปิด
เนาะก็อาจจะเป็นกลิ่นที่มันอื้อหือครูชิ
บอกกลิ่นเน่าเหรอคะโหไว้นานมากเลยนะแต่
ครูบุ๊คิดว่าอีกกลิ่นนึงค่ะมันคือกลิ่น
คาวค่ะ
อ๋อในตู้เย็นเนี่ยจะมีกลิ่นคาวของเนื้อ
สัตว์นะอย่างเช่นปลาอาจจะมีเนาะเลือด
เลือดของปลากลิ่นหมูกลิ่นไก่เนี่ยมันก็จะ
มีเลือดมีอะไรผสมอยู่เนาะมันก็อาจจะทำให้
เกิดกลิ่นคาวกลิ่นคาวกลิ่นเน่ากลิ่นอับ
โอ้โหกลิ่นอับยังเกิดจากอันนี้อีกอันค่ะ
เวลาเราถอดออกมา
แกลิ่นอับค่ะเพราะว่าพอคนเนี่ยมีเหงื่อ
ที่เท้าใช่มยแล้วก็สวมรองเท้าเข้าไปเนี่ย
แล้วไม่มีช่องระบายอาการเนี่ยมันก็เลย
เกิดความอับข้างในเพราะว่ามันมีความชื้น
ด้วยนิดหน่อยเนาะก็เหงื่อเหงื่อเราออก
ทั้งตัวเนาะมันก็มีกลิ่นเนาะไปผสมกับ
กลิ่นที่มันอับมันก็เลยกลายเป็นโอ้โห
เหม็นมากค่ะ
อื้อหือแล้วอีกอันนึงค่ะครูปุ๊กเวลาที่
เราบอกนะเรามีอะไรนะเหม็นฉุนเหม็นเปรี้ยว
เหม็นอับเหม็นเน่าเหม็นคาวเหม็นคาวคยังมี
อันนี้อีกค่ะ
อืเหม็นสาดเหม็นสาดเหม็นได้ยังไงคะคือ
เสื้อที่เราเก็บไว้นานๆเป็นปีๆอยู่ใน
กล่องหรืออะไรอย่างเงี้ยแล้วมันมีไข่ของ
ตัวนี้ค่ะอันนี้คือไข่นะไข่อะไรไข่แมลง
สาบค่ะครูปุ๊กโอซุปเหม็นสาบเลยค่ะแบบ
โอ้โหมันสมชื่อเลยค่ะว่ามันชื่อสาปเนี่ย
นะมันชื่อแมลงสาบมันเป็นแมลงชนิดนึงจริงๆ
แมงสาบใช่มั้ยอือแมงสาบใช่มยก็หรือว่า
แมลงสาบแมลงสาบนะแมลงสาบเนี่ยมันเหม็นสาบ
เนี่ยแหละค่ะเขาก็เลยมันเหม็นกลิ่นของมัน
เนี่ยแหละนะเราก็เลยเรียกว่าเหม็นสาบอื
เนาะแล้วก็แต่ตัวมันไม่ได้ใหญ่เท่าทีู่ชิ
โชว์นะคะนัก
เรียนตัวมันมีเล็กแล้วก็ใหญ่นิดนึงนะแมลง
เนี่ยที่ครูปุ๊กเห็นของประเทศนักเรียน
เนี่ยตัวใหญ่กว่าก็มีนะอย่างอเมริกาที่เ
เอาเลี้ยงอ่ะเอออันนั้นน่ะตัวใหญ่มากโอ้
อันเนี้ยเราเรียกว่าเหม็นสาบเพราะว่าไม่
ว่าจะเป็นโต๊ะใช่มยนักเรียนโต๊ะ
คอมพิวเตอร์ก็ได้มันมีลิ้นชักเวลานัก
เรียนปิดเปิดเนาะนะลิ้นชักเนี่ยเปิดออกมา
เนี่ยบางทีเนี่ยมีขี้แมลงสาบมีไข่ของแมลง
สาบอยู่อ่ะมันก็ก็จะมีกลิ่นสาบเหม็นสาบ
อ่ะเพมาจากไอตัวเนี้ยเขาคก็เลยเรียกว่า
เหม็นสาบค่ะครูชิเนี่ยค่ะถ้าเราเห็นตัว
เนี้ยเรารู้เลยว่าโอ้โหเสื้อผ้าเราเนี่ย
ต้องต้องซักแน่ๆเพราะว่ามันจะต้องเหม็น
สาปแน่ๆใช่ค่ะหนังสือก็เป็น
นะด้วยใช่ค่ะนะครูชิคะครูุอยากให้ครูชิ
เนี่ยโชว์อีกตัวนึงที่มันที่นักเรียนไป
บอกว่าแมลงสาบอ่ะแต่ว่ามันไม่ใช่อ่ะบอก
ว่าคนไทยกินแมลงสาบใช่มยใช่แล้วบอกว่าคน
ไทอ่ะกินแมลงสาบหรือว่าบางทีเห็นคนไทยทำ
อาหารแล้วก็ใส่ไอ้ตัวนี้ลงไปเนี่ยนะอัน
นี้ค่ะมันชื่ออะไรคะูชิอันนี้ชื่อแมงดา
ค่ะนะอันนี้เป็นแมงดาเนาะแมงดานาใช่ค่ะนะ
อันนี้ไม่เหมือนแมลงสาบนะคะตัวใหญ่กว่า
อันนี้ก็มีกลิ่นนะคะตัวนี้ก็เป็นกลิ่นแบบ
ฉุนฉุนใช่นะเจะเปรียบเทียบให้ดูกับแมลง
สาบนะอือค่ะอือไม่เหมือนกันนะนักเรียนดู
ขามันเนี่ยไม่เหมือนกันนะแมลงสาบกับแมง
แมงดานาเนี่ยนะเพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยกินแมง
ดานาเนาะเขาคก็จะเอาไปตำใส่น้ำพริกอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยแต่เขาจะกินเป็นตัวผู้ค่ะเพราะ
ว่าตัวผู้เนี่ยมันจะตอนที่มันจะแต่งงาน
เนี่ยมันจะปล่อยฟีโรโมนออกมาค่ะนะทำให้มี
กลิ่นฉุนเนี่ยค่ะนะก็นะโอ้โหครูชิวันนี้
ก็หมดเวลาอีกละเราเนี่ยนะคุยกันได้นิด
เดียวเองไม่เป็นไรค่ะก็ให้นักเรียนรู้จัก
ว่าเหม็นของเราเนี่ยมีหลายๆเหม็นค่ะมี
เหม็นสาบเหม็นเปรี้ยวเหม็น
คาวเหม็นอับเหมเหม็นสาบเหม็นเยอะเหม็น
เหม็นเยอะไปหมดนะนะเหม็นกลิ่นตัวว่างงั้น
นะคะก็เวลาหมดหมดเวลาเราก็ต้องลานักเรียน
ไปก่อนโอกาสหนก็จะมาคุยกันใหม่นะคะได้ค่ะ
เราก็มาพบกันใหม่นะคะนักเรียนอยากจะให้
เราคุยถึงเรื่องอะไรก็คอมเมนต์มาแล้วกัน
นะคะนะก็วันนี้ขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ